[Aplausos]
Benedicto 16 se caracterizó por ser uno
de los jerarcas de la Iglesia Católica
más conservadores
Muéstrame qué nuevo trajo Mahoma y
encontrarás solo cosas malvadas e
inhumanas
tenía posturas radicales contra otras
religiones y sobre el comportamiento de
la comunidad católica en 2013 se
convirtió en el primer papa en renunciar
a su cargo en 600 años generando un
terremoto dentro de la iglesia pasó
desde entonces a ser conocido como El
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 después de
haber examinado repetidamente mi
conciencia anterior he llegado a la
certeza de que mis fuerzas debido a la
edad avanzada ya no son adecuadas para
un ejercicio apropiado del Ministerio de
San Pedro
Joseph ratzinger nació el 16 de abril de
1927 en Alemania su juventud No fue
fácil en medio del auge del nazismo y él
la desencadenante Segunda Guerra Mundial
en la que ratzinger fue enrolado en las
juventudes hitlerianas desde el tercer
rey
tras el final de la guerra estudió
filosofía y teología y el 1951 inició su
carrera sacerdotal al ser ordenado como
cura en la catedral de fraising en 1977
ratzinger se convirtió en cardenal y un
año más tarde participó en los cónclaves
que resultaron en la elección de los
papas Juan Pablo I y Juan Pablo II en
1981 el papa Juan Pablo II lo designó
como director de la congregación para la
doctrina de la fe institución heredera
de la inquisición
su ascenso como máxima figura de la
Iglesia Católica en 2005 se produjo tras
el fallecimiento de Juan Pablo II de
quien fue su mano derecha
Joseph ratzinger eligió el nombre de
Benedicto 16 al convertirse en el papa
número 265 en la iglesia católica
laboratorio en la Viña del señor
su papado de siete años no estuvo exento
de la polémica los críticos lo asociaron
con el régimen nazi y lo acusaron de
encubrir casos de pedofilia en la
iglesia
[Música]
Benedicto 16 siempre aclaró que su
renuncia fue una elección consciente y
voluntaria pasó sus últimos años En un
convento en los jardines vaticanos
dedicado a la reflexión la escritura y
la música